(upbeat music)
- We see a lot of growth
in emerging markets.
A lot of those markets are mobile first,
and some of those users
actually access the internet
for the first time with their phones.
Most of the time the phones that they use
are based on Android.
Optimizing our application for Android
is something that is very important for us
as we look forward to delivering
a great experience in those markets.
App size is a very important
consideration for Netflix,
as a direct impact on the install rate.
When Google announced App
Bundle and Dynamic Delivery,
we were very excited about it.
It had a lot of potential
for us to leverage
and optimize the size of our application.
- To migrate to App Bundle
and dynamic features,
we had to first decide what to modularize.
We considered any sizeable
component that limited usage,
for example language
and subtitle features.
We made one of our features,
contacting the customer support, dynamic,
so if a user really needed this feature,
then they would go to help section,
and then this feature will
be downloaded for that user.
With the migration to App
Bundle and dynamic features
we were able to reduce the
app download size by 33%,
size reduction from 23
megabyte to 15 megabyte.
We have few more features
to make them dynamic,
and we're expecting further
savings in the coming months.